people approach housing services when
they're facing problems with where they
live these include being unable to pay
their rental mortgage being told to
leave by parents or fleeing violence
also where properties are unsuitable for
them due to disrepair such as severe
damp or having no heating as well as
being unable to use a bathroom
to solve these problems we try to help
people in their homes we offer advice
about housing rights links to specialist
services and support help with
adaptations such as level access showers
or stair lifts and financial assistance
to repair and improve properties
if it is not possible to remain at home
we also help people to move we work to
link people with private landlords to
find a new place to rent and help people
applying for affordable social housing
in order to do this we try to maximize
the accommodation available
we work with housing associations to
build new housing where people want to
live as well as the owners of empty
properties to bring them back into use